>> Laura: IT'S TIME FOR THE
SEEN AND UNSEEN SEGMENT.
APPARENTLY PRESIDENT TRUMP GETS
THE COLD SHOULDER FROM A ROYAL.
JOINING US WITH ALL THE DETAILS
ISN'T RAYMOND ARROYO.
OKAY, TELL ME THAT JOE BIDEN DID
NOT GET TOO CLOSE TO A YOUNG
LADY AGAIN?
>> I'M AFRAID HE DID.
IF YOU ARE JOE BIDEN THE ONE
IMAGE YOU WANT TO AVOID
DESCRIBING WOMEN AND CHILDREN IN
A WEIRD WAY.
YESTERDAY, JOE BIDEN TOOK A
QUESTION FROM A LITTLE GIRL AND
HE SAID THIS.
>> I BET YOU ARE AS BRIGHT AS
YOU ARE GOOD LOOKING, I TELL
YOU.
>> WHY IS HE TELLING A LITTLE
CHILD THAT SHE IS GOOD-LOOKING?
>> Laura: IT'S THE HANDS.
>> OH, YES, HE WASN'T FINISHED.
SHE TOLD HIM HE WANTED TO BE A
JOURNALIST AND SO HE PROCESSED
HER OVER TO THE PRESS CORPS.
SHE FINALLY DEPOSITED THE LITTLE
GIRL INTO A DEPRESSED PEN.
MY THOUGHT IS WHY IS JOE BIDEN
SEPARATING CHILDREN FROM THEIR
PARENTS AND CONFINING THEM TO
PRESS PENS?
>> Laura: HE SEPARATING
CHILDREN, THAT WAS ALL I DO.
>> HE'S ALREADY PROMISE.
IF THIS IS MY WORST THING, I
DON'T MEAN ANYTHING BY IT.
>> SPEAKING OF PUBLIC MISSTEPS,
ON JUNE 3RD QUEEN ELIZABETH WILL
WELCOME PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS
FAMILY TO BUCKINGHAM PALACE FOR
A STATE VISIT WHICH YOU AND I
WILL BE COVERING.
WERE MEMBERS OF THE ROYAL FAMILY
WILL ATTEND THE LUNCH, BUT HIS
WIFE MEGHAN MARKLE WILL NOT BE
ATTENDING.
THE DUCHESS OF SUSSEX WILL NOT
BE ATTENDING AS WINS OR CLAIMS
SHE IS STILL ON MATERNITY LEAVE
AND HAS NOT DONE ANY PUBLIC
EVENT SINCE HER SON'S BIRTH LAST
MONTH.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> IF MICHELLE AND BARACK OBAMA
WERE IN TOWN I THINK THE
MATERNITY LEAVE MAY HAVE BEEN
CUT SHORT.
>> SHE IS GOING TO THE QUEEN'S
BIRTHDAY.
>> SHE SEEN SOME TYPE OF
HOT YOGA CLASS, SHE COULD GET
OUT TO THAT.
HERE SHE IS IN 2016, DISCUSSING
THEN CANDIDATE TRUMP.
>> THAT'S A HUGE NUMBER AND AS
MISOGYNIST AS TRUMP IS AND AS
VOCAL AS HE IS, THAT'S A HUGE
THING.
>> SHE LOOKS TOTALLY DIFFERENT.
AND THE BABY IS ADORABLE.
I LIKE KATE MIDDLETON.
I KNOW PEOPLE ARE WORRIED ABOUT
THE WORLD SERIES AND OTHER BIG
SPORTING EVENTS BUT THERE IS ONE
THAT I HAD TO BRING YOU BECAUSE
YOU MIGHT HAVE MISSED IT.
WORLD CHAMPIONSHIP IS NOW AND
IT'S 43RD GEAR, TOW WRESTLING.
DO YOU KNOW THE SKILL IT TAKES
TO TRAIN A TOE AND SUBJECTED TO
THIS KIND OF GRUELING CHALLENGE?
THEY WRAP THE TOES AND TRY TO
MOVE THE PERSON ON THE OTHER
SIDE.
THIS YEAR'S WORLD CHAMPION WAS
NO, NONE OTHER THAN ALAN NASTY
NASH.
>> IT WAS 25 YEARS, I HAVE NO
INTENTION.
>> ENGLAND, THERE IS A SEPARATE
LADY'S DIVISION.
LISA TWINKLE TOES SHRIMPTON, NOT
A JOKING MATTER.
THEY TRAIN ALL YEAR AND THEY
EXERCISE THOSE BUNIONS.
WATCH.
>> DOES A LOT OF THINGS THAT A
LOT OF PEOPLE DO.
I HAD THAT TOENAILS REMOVED ON
MY FEET REMOVED FOR TOE
WRESTLING PURPOSES, SO THERE'S A
LOT OF THINGS YOU CAN DO AND